please welcome the absolutely beautiful
iris apatown
[Applause]
you know i met your sister um judd and
leslie judd was doing some
uh writing on the wedding singer oh yeah
and i met your sister when she was a
baby i know i know i've all just
watched you've watched us grow up i mean
i like literally have
felt like
when i was growing up people like oh you
look like a little drew barrymore so i
started copying you for my whole life
which sounds creepy no but i literally
have
like copied like even this this is like
your niche like dark hair from the 90s
and i was like yeah i'll do that one too
like you know what we actually pulled a
couple images look at us hair twinning
right there there's one oh my goodness i
love this god you're so stunning there's
another
it's funny because you know your sister
um has really like come into the
forefront um in euphoria like i'm i'm
like oh my god i feel like the entire
show is becoming about her i know
i'm not such a style
trendsetter i mean can you believe the
influence that the show has had on hair
makeup wardrobe all of it oh yeah i'm
like immediately when it came out i
remember like me and my friends would
put like gems all over our eyes before
parties and like it changed everything
which is so cool and it's i remember
like my sister would call me from her
trailer i would screenshot every look
just to like copy it before it came out
to make me look original but look it's
called inspo for a reason exactly but do
you like the show i love the show that's
like my favorite show me and my friends
like do watch parties for every weekend
you do oh and it was out we did yeah we
were oh my god you mean like you and
your bestie olivia rodrigo
[Music]
um
okay what do i need to know about olivia
rodrigo through her best friend's eyes
well we well we live together so we do
okay this must be the coolest house in
all of the planets we have sex in the
city movie night i mean it just makes me
happy it's like one of those things i
also loved the reboot i i was i loved it
i wish i hope it comes back for season
two i hope it does too i miss kim
cattrall bring her back oh it's so sad
that she's not
and what are the odds of her coming back
she's coming back they can't hide it
from us i know she's coming back i want
it let's go on a campaign
[Applause]
all right so you have this lovely
boyfriend you're out there in the world
um ryder robinson
um who is just so delightful and
charming
what are you guys up to how's that going
and um
oh just i'm so excited um it's going
very well we
have been together for a while and he's
just like been such like a lovely angel
in my life it's a very refreshing when
you grow up in high school and just like
dating around like i
i had my fair share of weirdos so it's
nice to come
to somebody that just wants you to be
happy and like
you know
seeing what can be healthy is really
nice very
very refreshing and he makes me very
happy
so happy for you thanks so happy your
parents have been such couple goals to
all of us yeah no i think
they're
very like much so like what i look for
in my love life because they'll just sit
together for like four hours just
talking and i'm like wow
what are you guys talking about like
it's not like it's nice to see that like
after
however many years 25 or something they
can still
you know
make each other laugh that hard and be
like best friends with each other
but
that is the example yeah that that is
the goal what i look like
look for i guess you're a teenager or a
full blown grown-up we could just be
nice to each other exactly so tell me
about the bubble this is another family
affair courtesy of the app towels yes um
the bubble follows some actors shooting
a movie in a bubble in a bubble in
london so they basically like live in
this
beautiful like english countryside
castle
and are like having people serve them
and
they're just kind of
self-centered and like bratty i guess is
the word they're just like it's you know
how it could everything that could go
wrong when making a movie during
you know lockdown then i think that's
what makes it kind of silly because
there's there's humor to be found in
that and you know isolation but
um
mostly just because of their behavior
and how it's so bad
[Music]
you